روسيا تعلن السيطرة على
إحدى أكبر المدن الأوكرانية،
وأوكرانيا تدعو لنقل ٣٠٠٠جثة
لجنود روسيا من البلاد،
مجلس الأمن يفشل في اعتماد قرار
يدين هجوم روسيا على أوكرانيا.
وروسيا تعلن ضرب مطار هيثرو
في العاصمة البريطانية لندن،
وترسل رسالة تهديد وتحدٍ للجميع..
قوات روسيا تستأنف هجماتها
بعد وقوف مؤقت للتفاوض..
وحرب العصابات على الأبواب
فهل تلقى روسيا نفس مصيرها السابق
في أفغانستان؟
دعم غربي عسكري سخي لكييف
وسط حصار على أبواب العاصمة الأوكرانية.
وحظر للتجوال في أوكرانيا،
واستسلام دفعة أوكرانية جديدة...
مع تزايد القلق من كارثة نووية
كهيروشيما لكن هذه المرة
في الأراضي الأوكرانية،...
مقطع فيديو لرئيس أوكرانيا زيلينسكي
ولبعض من كبار مسؤلي كييف
من وسط شوارع العاصمة،،
يقول الرئيس هنا والمسؤولون هنا
والقوات هنا والشعب الأوكراني هنا
وسنحمي عاصمتنا....
زيلينسكي علينا أن نقاوم وعلينا أن ننتظر
فمصير أوكرانيا يتقرر الآن
ولن نخسر عاصمتنا...
الرئيس الأوكراني قال لرئيسة المفوضية الأوروبية
نحن ندافع عن حريتنا وعن أوروبا
ويطلب منها دعما عاجلا..
في حين استهدف الجيش الروسي
محطة كهرباء كييف ..
أوكرانيا تقول إنها أعطبت ٢٢ دبابة روسية
في ميليوبول..
والدفاع الروسية ترد وتقول
أن آلاف من قواتها تتجه نحو مدينة ميليبول..
وذلك بعد أن فرضت السيطرة على
كامل مدينة  الأوكرانية بحسب الوزارة الروسية
وأكدت تدمير ٨٢١ منشأة عسكرية
من بينها ١٤ مطارا عسكريا
و١٩ مركز قيادة و٢٤ منظومة دفاع جوي
من طراز s300, و٤٨ محطة رادار
وإسقاط ٧ من مقاتلات الجو في أوكرانيا
و٧ مروحيات و٩ مسيرات..
وتدمير ٨٧ دبابة وعدد من المدرعات..
ورئيسة الحكومة الأوكرانية ترد
بمناشدة الصليب الأحمر بنقل ٣آلاف جثة
من قتلى الجيش الروسي
وتقول أنها مساعدة إنسانية ولتعلم روسيا
أيضا عدد ضحاياها في هذه الحرب...
لكن حكومة موسكو تنفي ذلك..
كل الأماكن مغلقة في أوكرانيا
والسلطات ستتعامل مع من يخرج
بعد الساعة الخامسة على أنه عدو..
فهناك حظر تجوال من الساعة ال٥ مساءا
حتى الثامنة صباحا والناس خائفة تترقب...
(تشيرنوبل كهيروشما)
الخطر يزداد بعد سيطرة روسيا
على مفاعل تشيرنوبل وارتفاع اشعاعه
أعلى ب٢٠ مرة عن مستوياته الطبيعية،
بسبب حركة المعدات الثقيلة
في المنطقة التي أدت إلى ارتفاع الغبار
المشع إلى طبقات  الهواء في المنطقة
العازلة المحيطة بمحطة الطاقة المهجورة،
والتي تبلغ مساحتها ٤٠٠٠ كيلو متر مربع..
هذا المفاعل انفجر خلال اختبار أمني
عام ١٩٨٦ مسببا أسوأ كارثة نووية..
على إثرها تسرب إشعاع نووي يعادل
٥٠٠ قنبلة من هيروشيما وتوفي آنذاك
٩٣ ألف شخص متأثرين بالإشعاع..
وفي أوكرانيا ١٥ مفاعل نووي تؤمن نصف التيار
الكهربائي فإذا اندلعت معارك بالقرب منها
قد نشهد هيروشيما مرة أخرى..
فهل تتسبب روسيا بكارثة إنسانية أخرى
على غرار الكارثة التي ارتكبتها أمريكا في اليابان..
الهجوم الروسي لا يتوقف وهذه المرة بهجوم
عن طريق الحرب السيبرانية
تم ضرب مطار هيثرو بلندن،
حيث تم اختراق نظام تشغيل المطار
وتعطيله تماما وخرج عن الخدمة،
وهذا يعني أن بوتين يقول للعالم أن روسيا
لن تقف أمام العقوبات الغربية والأمريكية
وأن الضربات الروسية ستطال كل العواصم الأوروبية
بوتين يعلن أن العاصمة كييف محاصرة
وكذلك العاصمة الاقتصادية لأوكرانيا
خاركيف، وقال
( مهمة الجيش الروسي ليست اقتحام المدن
وإنما محاصرته بانتظار استسلام الجيش الأوكراني،،
وأنهم لا يحاربون الجيش الأوكراني
أساسا بل يحاربون المتطرفين العملاء لأمريكا،
وعلى رأسهم رئيس أوكرانيا وهي التشكيلات
المسؤولة عن التطهير العرقي في الدونباس
ويضيف بوتين:
من خلال استخباراتنا نرى هؤلاء المتطرفين
يعملون وسط المدن في الواقع هم يتصرفون
كما يتصرف الإرهابيون ويختبئون وراء المدنيين
كل هذا يحدث بوجود المستشارين الأجانب
وبتوصيات من مستشارين أمريكيين) ..
(وأناشد الجنود الأوكرانيين مرة أخرى
ألا يفعلوا ذلك لا تدعو النازيين الجدد
يستخدمون زوجاتكم وأطفالكم كدروع بشرية) ...
بوتين يعلنها صراحة ويدعو قادة الجيش للانقلاب
على السلطة ويقول
(انقلبوا على السلطة وتعالوا لنتفاوض
وسيكون ذلك أسهل بالنسبة لروسيا...
أنتم بديل عن الحكومة النازية مدمنة المخدرات
هم عصابة حولوا الشعب الأوكراني لدروع بشرية)
بينما كانت روسيا قد أمرت  قواتها بهجوم
واسع النطاق بعد توقف قالت أنه كان بهدف
ترك فرصة للتفاوض بين موسكو وكييف،
ثم استأنفت الهجمات بعد رفض كييف للتفاوض
من جهته خرج زيلينسكي ليقول أن المفاوضات
مع روسيا لم تصل إلى أهدافها فالروس اشترطوا
شروطا تعجيزية،  وأعلن بدء المقاومة الشعبية،
وبذلك بدأت الشرطة الأوكرانية ووزعت
على الشعب الأسلحة الخفيفة..
وقال زيلينسكي أن هذه اللحظات لحظات
استراتيجية حاسمة لإنهاء سنوات من المناقشات
لانضمام أوكرانيا للاتحاد الأوروبي
وانضمامهم يعني علامة رئيسية لدعم الأوروبيين لهم....
فهل تتحقق أمنية الأوكراني؟
من جانبه بايدن بدأ بالتراجع وقال..
(كما قلت لكم الأسبوع الماضي
فإن الدفاع عن الحرية سيكلفنا الكثيير)
(ما يعني ارتفاع أسعار الغاز على المواطنين
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية في ظل رفض
دول الخليج زيادة انتاج النفط والغاز
لكي تنخفض أسعاره وقال قادة الخليج
أنهم لن يدفعوا فاتورة الحرب الروسية
وليس من شأنهم، وهذا أمر يخص الأمريكان )
(أبرز الأحداث الغربية ردا على موسكو)
دخول العقوبات الأوروبية ضد روسيا حيز التنفيذ...
وبداية الخسائر...
..وتم توقيع عقوبات على ٨ من النخبة المقربة
من بوتين وعلى ٣٣٩ عضوا من البرلمان الروسي ..
هو سيل من العقوبات الاقتصادية
بهدف إضعاف الجانب الاقتصادي لروسيا
وردعها عن إسقاط أوكرانيا...
أعلنت هولندا تقديم ٢٠٠ صاروخ مضاد للطيران
وأضافت أن أوكرانيا طلبت دعم إضافي
وأنها ستلبي طلبها وأن أسلحة أخرى
ورادارات يتم شحنها وسترسل إلى أوكرانيا
في أسرع وقت ممكن..
ماكرون بوتين اختار الحرب من جانب واحد
والحرب ستطول والوضع الإنساني مأساوي..
ونحن بصدد تجهيز خطة لمواجهة الوضع الاقتصادي
عقب تنفيذ العقوبات....
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي بلينكن يعلن
عن مساعدة جديدة لأوكرانيا
بقيمة ٣٥٠مليون دولار..
ويبدو أن الحرب ليست إلا في بدايتها.
فهل تتوقف وهي في مهدها؟